oh I just noticed this thing came off we
can't have this there's got to be
continuity between the [__] shows
here ah Jesus Christ this thing never
comes off it's right when you tape a
[__] special and everything just
falls apart Royal Al Hall huh where did
you buy this mik stand huh where the
[__] did you get
this you know the mic stand guys all
[__] pissed off right it's a j good
[__] mik I know f [__]
yank [__] y off on everything [__]
falls off on
it how dare you the queen comes down
here and sits in a box and watches the
show you know what I heard about you
guys actually by the way I've been over
here for a week and as an American I got
to say something you guys are pretty fat
too been on the same tour for this hour
for almost over a year now um dude
band's tour for like four years and then
[__] go right back back in the studio
make another one and keep going you got
to toughen up man yeah you're right huh
you know what do I do camouflage hat
looking like a [__] Backwoods guy all
tough and [__] you can't handle doing
your hour again I mean come on man suck
it up so I finally walked up to this old
New York door guy and I was just like
dude what's going on what's with all
these people here and he was just like
oh no no no don't worry he goes it's
June he goes it's pride month and I'm
like what's that you know I'm 52 I never
heard of it right they didn't have that
when I was a kid he goes oh it's a pride
month and I was just like
oh dude you know when you're just like
stuck in The Matrix and you just can't
everything's just pressed up you can't
see anything and then somebody gives you
that little nugget of information that
just pulls it back like why is it so
crowded it's gay pride moth ah tank tops
0% body fat two guys kissing Rainbow
Flags
ah if I give you this will you give me
start giving [__] about the [__]
cheating I'll give you this and I'll
give you this you give me dollars yeah
yeah shut the [__] up now about the
cheating now he's trying to go
aggressive you going try to gorilla your
way through this no keep your chips
you're a piece of [__] you're a piece of
[__] we don't care about money here it's
all about he just tried to buy it out
with like 11 bucks buy now will this
shut you up like he just pulled up in a
roll a [__] [__] okay they're
always talking about how to make a woman
happy but I don't think they do it
enough to help you guys out how to make
a man happy right the great thing about
men is we're simple so here's the thing
right here you want to make a guy happy
how about four times a year once a
season you go out to the kitchen without
him saying [__] you go out to the
kitchen you make a sandwich you get him
a beer you walk out you give it to him
you don't say a word and you just
[__]
leave you do that you keep them happy
that's all it takes now I know right out
of the gate this is coming off sex right
it's cuz I'm saying go out in the
kitchen make your man a sandwich I'm not
saying women belong in the kitchen
barefoot and pregnant rubbing my balls
I'm not saying that grab a beer walk out
just hand it to him don't say [__] and
then [__] leave and when I say leave
I mean leave I don't mean walk into
another room for like 10 minutes and
then stick your head back and just be
like did you like it was it good great
don't yell at me I just made you a
sandwich they took away our strength and
tipped it in their favor hey good on
them but then don't come back at us and
and then you stole our offense and won a
Super Bowl fantastic I get it this is
big boy stuff but don't come back and
start
crying Bill Burr here on the I love it's
like those those Trump guys they're
always going like ah you snowflakes F
your feelings and all of that and then
you make fun of trump they're like oh my
God it's so
disrespectful it's like you're saying F
Joe Biden it's like you can't have it
both ways so that's my thing as a pets
fan okay it's just like if you're doing
it too quit your crying
quit your crying I mean you know how's
your uh how's your wife's uh hands doing
these days oh they're fantastic I love
my wife you know where you stand with
her okay the guy walked in the arena
everybody cheered she gave him the
finger nobody got arrested that's why
this country's great everybody expressed
themselves can we all be adults I mean I
don't know about you but I came there to
go to the fights I didn't know I was
going to the Republican National
Convention my wife favorite thing was
when Trump was going thank you thank you
you know what it reminded me of when OJ
got acquitted remember that when he's
going thank you like I can't believe I'm
getting off of this thank you thank you
Tom left bich and there was this sense
that bich wore his ass out he was
exhausted from it if you had to pick oh
my God are you GNA go Real Housewives on
me here well I'm saying you weren't in
the locker room you don't know what
happened you talk to some other guy who
never played professional sports by the
water cooler you know don't know what
happen that's that's all my ink I have
this uh mic on so yeah that's all right
be a gentleman and help me off with
my hey Cody can you believe that
marriage didn't work
out yeah I can't believe your
relationships don't work
out um here I'm I'm you can ask me about
anything you want yeah I'm blind to of
course I'm interested hey let me help
out before you yell at me again look
there you
go ah there you go the love there's the
Love by the way dude the Elk's been
delicious thank you how you like it I've
been chowing it for like four days like
out of respect for that [__] elk that
you shot it's like I'm eating all this
[__] I don't care if it's [__] bed
does it make you more aggressive what
elk no Joe you [__]
[Applause]
lunatic somebody gets in my face that
might cause me to get more
lunatic I eat a little bit of
protein you had to beat the [__] out of
people for like three decades before you
could like chill smoke a little weed put
on your Little Rascal's hat and just
[__] chill
out you don't
understand I love him to death but this
guy is the most
testosterone [__] filed dude I've
ever met that's why I love him I love
him first of all it what really counts
is who's scarier dude there's no way I'd
ever let you get those Farm hands on
me there
just Farm hands yeah you guys can
literally [__] change a tire how
beautiful I love you could change a tire
with like a crescent wrench just [__]
come up just just [__] turn it like
that do you know you and Mario Bali have
the exact same
hands what are you talking about I used
to love watching Mario molto Mario when
he he would make the pasta with the well
method I got to know his hands those
[__] sausage
fingers are you attacking my hands I'm a
hand model no like when we do I don't
really believe in much like I don't
believe in Santa Claus I don't think
Jesus you going to tell the kids this
well Jesus was like the first Chris
Angel you
know Chris Angel is doing Chris Angel is
doing everything that Jesus did other
than pour pulling the fish out he's
walking on water too you know
they both got the long hair and the good
body they don't wear shirts you
know I just don't like no I'm really
like I know what I'm going to tell my
kids when they get into a certain age I
I really am like I have it down about
religion and and people really
narcissists sociopaths all of this type
of stuff like you want to see a great
case thing on like narcissism Liberals
are so stupid the way that they handle
Trump
what do you mean you should shut up he's
a narcissist neutral energy yeah you
neutral you think he'd go away you know
I think he was I think he was a one hit
wonder uhhuh right he wrote The Twist
and then that was it he was on the
casino circuit and then you idiot
liberals wrote him twist again when you
indicted him and now he's a martyr
coming back Jimmy temperament twist is
back coming back it's going to be great
for comedy he's coming
back sorry $9,000 to [__] fly here
you know what I mean no offense but
there's no Eiffel Tower here I think
that's a little
pricey thank you you're
welcome thank you for not just laughing
thank you for verbally letting me know
that you appreciated that thank
[Applause]
youc she either has no stairs in in her
house or someone doesn't know how to
walk up them
that's that
boy did you call did you call a
CL thank
[Music]
you that's way she said it she said it
not like I was 10 ft away she said it
like I was downstairs in the recck
room changing a fuse or something that's
not
it I still that
working hey hey it's on it's on okay
thank you
thought you
said and come to think of it I got
addicted to you oh no no
no and come to think of it I need
somebody like you oh no no I need
someone like
[Music]
you
oh I'm just [__] with you feminism
doesn't bug me you know it doesn't
bother me I'm not afraid of it or
anything like that you know for the
simple fact that I know it's going to
fail you know and I I take comfort in
that I do I'm not rooting for it
because I know it doesn't like
me
um yeah do you know why you know I think
it's not going to survive why it's not
going to be successful anyways because
they still need men's help to make it
happen I don't understand it I don't
understand why women just can't work
with each other
and make this [__] happen they keep
coming to us like you more men need to
care about this issue where are the men
to stand up and say
something like why do I have to [__]
say
something this is your [__]
problem why are you always dragging us
into this [__] shut the door uh give me
some water though come back Jesus Christ
yes you're I'm a man I asked you to do
something you're a woman you go and you
do it you don't ask questions Phil I
swear to
God so anyway it's like I was saying
they're sitting there [__] moaning and
complaining about all the stuff they
don't have but we really you know and
it's like you [__] outlive us you
outli us well you know what you have a
birthday coming up I know exactly what
I'm getting you big bag of Fritos you're
an
[__] yeah so they're always [__]
Ming and complaining about what they
don't have right you know do they have a
look around and see what they do have a
whole [__] platoon of shoes huh that
their guy paid for I'll tell you what I
have bag for a husband oh snap 12 to six
right there
baby hey NE you know why I make more an
hour than you cuz I'm better than you
you with your girlfriend living in La
yes I am I'm technically married but I'm
married how like I want to be married
yeah which is I don't sign that Behind
the Music music contract where you know
everything works out until it doesn't
work out yeah no you see suet mosy one
of the greatest boxers of all time he's
losing his championship belt in a
divorce that's losing yeah it's like
you're trying to break a man why does
she want those right break they go with
their
shoes you
know no and I love how when you get a
divorce all of a sudden it costs like 50
Grand a month to give a kid fro Loops
right these guys I'm telling you is an
epidemic of Gold Digging [__] in this
country and it is just not being
addressed on any level what are you
talking about what do you mean what am I
talking about every guy out there is
just getting nobody's safe oh my
nobody's safe football players actors
politicians nobody they never get called
horse Arnold Schwarz 's maid is still
called the maid in the story she knew
his wife on a firstname basis hooked up
with this dude in their bed and is still
called the maid why did she bang him why
because of that 1987 flat top He Still
rocking right you don't think it's
because of that Kindergarten Cop money
he's got laying around the
world I'm not and listen I'm not
condoning what the man did but you know
there just needs to be guys need to be
educated there's nothing out there to
help a guy handle becoming rich and
famous for that that that platoon of
[__] that's going to come over the
hill like like Braveheart faces painted
skirt on
just yes there's nothing out
there no it's like guys never learn how
to keep themselves in check Society does
it for you yeah just women aren going to
bang you because you drive the forklift
at Home Depot right despite the fact
that you want to bang all of them
they're not going to do it so you didn't
keep yourself in check the forklift job
did right then all of a sudden you hit a
lot the lottery you know yeah and then
you can just give into all of that like
I don't I'm so sick of all these trolls
coming on
TV judging these Great
Men these Great Men all these guys
anytime one of these guys gets caught
for screwing around these guys come
waddling out of their cubicles with
their jbls absolutely reprehensible
Behavior like they have any idea what
it's like to be tempted at that level
you know yeah as you walk over to your
Ford Focus are you really beating these
women off of you all those people who
judge Tiger Woods how many people he
golf what was the last time you walked
off the 18th hole and there was a
busload of Scandinavian women waiting to
hump your brains out and you're like
sorry
ladies you know